tutti benvenuti all'arena di verona
partiamo da un filmato
[Musica]
va bene
eccoci di nuovo qua con la storia di
chiara e fedez benvenuti chiara
benvenuto fede
ciao maria fedez ha deciso di cantanti
una canzone
prego fedez biondi tuoi capelli azzurri
tuoi occhi
se la mia raviolone che nessuno ti
tocchi non servono anelli per tenerci
assieme ma per comprarti stupri loco o
venduto anche un rene
vai matto
mi vuoi sposare raviolo
raviolo la viola dove sei
sono qui raviolo da è morto
fatto si conclude qui un altro cono
grazie ragazzi per averci fatto
emozionare in collegamento c'è una
persona che vorrebbe qualcosa lei maria
guarda io volevo solo dire che sono
molto molto felice parlare mi sono
veramente una bellissima coppia è molto
originale tra l'altro la scelta
all'arena di verona ma non l'avevo mai
fatto nessuna proposta ii e scusa sono
un po inacidita pro che comunque sta
aspettando la proposta di andrea che
però i suoi tempi vorrei neanche tutti
come insomma prima o poi arriva mente
per un'estate franti most amazing dei my
life gate attiva in now and then ho
contattato già giovanni perché saranno
uno sponsor ufficiale del master of the
nella base di ravioli e cioè la casa che
veramente a one thing e che è un momento
livello della mia vita e non ho un
telefono in mano
quindi ragazzi per aver cioè la
tecnologia deve stare fuori e questi
momenti e so che sono 700 camera 20
hanno ripreso e sono contenta che sia
tutti parole ci seguite
sì però monete da farvi la foto che
inserendo un campo la mano
alla prossima puntata ciao